recommendation from a government
advisory panel out this morning suggest
new screening guidelines for prostate
cancer US Preventive Services Task Force
says men aged 55 269 should discuss
potential benefits and downsides of
blood testing with their doctor but
there is no apparent benefit of
screening from men 70 and older
previously the panel recommended no
screening our dr. David agus leads a
Norris Westside Cancer Center at USC he
joins us from Los Angeles good morning
morning charlie so what caused this well
there was a study in Europe showing that
if you screen there's about a twenty
percent drop in the death rate and a
thirty percent drop and we call
metastatic disease or disease that has
spread so new data caused them to shift
their guidelines in addition there's a
shift now that if you are diagnosed with
prostate cancer almost a third of men
don't need to be treated and they could
be followed what we call active
surveillance so all of that data
together cause the United States
Preventive task force to shift the
recommendation from addie to a C which
means the benefits slightly out ray the
risks is it possible do we assume that
most doctors will now recommend against
screening well I think it's recommending
for screening at me know soon yeah so
you know the assumption it's hard to
know but but clearly the data show is
that a doctor and a patient need to
start to have discussions at around age
50 based on family history and based on
the value system of the patient whether
they should under grow screaming
understanding the risks so it really
requires the discussion is there a
reliable way to tell which of these
cancers may be deadly well biopsy I mean
so when you look at that biopsy we know
that some of them are indolent and don't
need to be treated others can be very
aggressive and so by looking under the
microscope you can know that but right
now we don't have a blood test that can
do that it requires a needle in a biopsy
I mean this now let's talk about breast
cancer screening because a new letter
published by the Journal of American
Medical Association acknowledges that
there's a divide now among doctors about
when to get mammograms it's just further
confusion is that we're seeing now is
that the guidelines are changing and
doctors are shifting in the direction of
doing more testing and so you know even
the data now is showing that maybe you
can wait later till age 52 doing
screaming they're doing screening
earlier and I think doctors say listen
more is probably better but hopefully
there's a discussion in the room with
the patient and based on their value
system and family history the right
decisions are made but there's a lot of
noise in the field David when you say
more is probably better that suggests
there's some window there where more
isn't necessarily better how big of a
problem is over screening and
overtreatment it's hard to know but but
clearly we are over screening and over
treating but many women will say listen
I want to do everything I can so I can
avoid breast cancer and play with my
grandchildren and others are saying
listen I want to go exactly with the
data and so there's no right answer
these are really hard studies to do that
take many decades and it's very hard to
randomize somebody and say you're going
to get you know no screening and you'll
get screening and let's see what happens
so there's a lot of noise in the space
as I say and discussions need to happen
and it's difficult because you need
10-15 minutes with a doctor to
understand there is some benefits and
make the right decision for you dr.
David egg is trying to make it clear for
us thanks for your time